This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When Eric Carlson retired, he dove headfirst into an old hobby. Philataly. Philataly is basically the love of stamps and it involves all aspects of stamp collecting from beginners to experts. Aside from being my new favorite word, Philataly is a tragically underappreciated field of study. A stamp can give you a perfect snapshot of the past in a single square inch of paper. Producer Vivian Le.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。埃里克·卡尔森退休后，一头扎进了一个旧爱好中：集邮。集邮本质上是对邮票的热爱，它涵盖了从初学者到专家在邮票收集方面的方方面面。除了成为我最喜欢的新词之外，集邮还是一个被严重低估的研究领域。一枚邮票可以在一平方英寸的纸上为你提供过去完美的缩影。制作人：薇薇安·勒。
Of course, you've got the basic forever stamp with the flag waving on it. Then there are maritime stamps, commemorative stamps, architectural stamps, or my favorite Cinderella's, which resemble real stamps but can't be used for mail since they aren't issued by a postal authority. They're kind of like fan art.
当然，你有印着飘扬旗帜的基础款“永恒邮票”。此外还有海事邮票、纪念邮票、建筑邮票，或者我最喜欢的“灰姑娘邮票”，它们看起来像真正的邮票，但因为不是由邮政部门发行的，所以不能用于邮寄。它们有点像同人艺术。
Eric Carlson finds his stamps at the world's great supermarket for obscure collectibles, eBay. And one day, he found this really odd looking stamp, a Cinderella, actually. It's a very cumbersome looking red bird in the middle with a yellow background. Most official stamps are neat and tidy with clean lines, but not this one. This stamp was kind of rough looking. The lettering was hand drawn and the bird in the center was beautiful, but also a bit in elegant. Eric bought two. They're very charming, just in their simplicity and their
埃里克·卡尔森在世界最大的稀有收藏品超市——eBay上寻找他的邮票。有一天，他发现了一枚看起来非常奇怪的邮票，实际上是一枚“灰姑娘邮票”。它中间是一只看起来很笨拙的红鸟，背景是黄色的。大多数正式邮票线条整洁利落，但这枚不是。这枚邮票看起来有点粗糙。字母是手绘的，中间的鸟很漂亮，但也有一点不优雅。埃里克买了两个。它们非常迷人，仅仅是因为它们的简洁和粗糙。
crudeness, sir. They're a joy to look at. He also didn't recognize the letters across the top, G-B-L-A. At first, I thought it was an acronym for some nation that escaped my attention. But the G-B-L-A wasn't a nation, or a postal authority, or any type of government body. It stood for the Great Bitter Lake Association.
先生，它们看起来令人愉悦。他还认不出顶部的字母“G-B-L-A”。起初，我以为这是某个我没注意到的国家的缩写。但“G-B-L-A”不是一个国家，也不是邮政部门，更不是任何类型的政府机构。它代表“大苦湖协会”。
Eric had stumbled upon the remnants of a forgotten bit of world history, left over from a rag-tag group of sailors, stranded at the center of a war. All my life has been attached to the sea. I'm more suited to a sea life. I don't think I'd be any good in an office scenario. I wouldn't fit in no Vivian. As much as I want to tell you this is Michael Cain, it is not.
埃里克偶然发现了一段被遗忘的世界历史残片，这是一群被困在战争中心、乌合之众般的船员留下的。我的一生都与大海相连。我更适合海上生活。我觉得我不适合办公室环境。我无法融入，薇薇安。虽然我很想告诉你这是迈克尔·凯恩，但并不是。
My name is Peter Flake. I'm now 77 years of age. Quite a senior citizen, as you can imagine, at 77. Flack is retired now, but at the age of 16, he started a long career in the merchant navy working on commercial cargo ships, mostly in the Atlantic. And by his early 20s, he was ready to see something new.
我叫彼得·弗莱克。我现在77岁了。正如你所想象的，77岁已经是位相当资深的老人了。弗莱克现在退休了，但在16岁时，他开始了在商船队工作的漫长职业生涯，主要是在大西洋航行。20出头时，他准备去看看新鲜事物。
I thought I wanted to see another part of the world, and I thought, oh, the fire east is, I like to see the fire east. In the mid-1960s, FLAQ was assigned on trade routes that took him from the UK to Asia. They'd haul everything from rubber to timber to toys. Japan, Hong Kong, Singapore, that's where we've discharged and then loaded up again, and then on our way back to the UK, via the Suez Canal, which was our normal route. The Suez Canal is one of the busiest and most important shipping routes in the world. It connects the Red Sea to the Mediterranean,
我想去看看世界的另一部分，我想，哦，远东，我想看看远东。20世纪60年代中期，弗莱克被分配到从英国到亚洲的贸易航线上。他们运送从橡胶到木材再到玩具的所有东西。日本、香港、新加坡，那是我们卸货然后再次装货的地方，然后经由苏伊士运河返回英国，这是我们的常规路线。苏伊士运河是世界上最繁忙、最重要的航运路线之一。它连接红海和地中海，
allowing quick passage from Asia to Europe through the Middle East. While flagship was busy delivering commercial goods from Singapore to the UK, tensions were escalating all around the canal. There have been border disputes and skirmishes for years between Israel and its neighboring countries, Egypt, Jordan, and Syria. But on June 5, 1967, things reached a breaking point, and the Six Day War began.
允许从亚洲经中东快速通往欧洲。当弗莱克的船忙于将商业货物从新加坡运往英国时，运河周围的紧张局势正在升级。以色列与其邻国埃及、约旦和叙利亚之间多年来一直存在边界争端和冲突。但1967年6月5日，局势达到了临界点，“六日战争”爆发了。
Unfortunately for Peter Flack, he and his ship, the Agapinor, were on their way home via the Suez Canal, which was right at the heart of the conflict. We were in the line of ships. Our ship was the last but one. It was common for ships from different countries to pass through in a convoy together, because it was easier to control traffic that way. The Agapinor was one of 14 cargo ships and two tankers grouped together. Not long into the journey, the convoy entered a section of the Suez called the Great Bitter Lake. It's a hundred square mile body of saltwater in the canal.
不幸的是，彼得·弗莱克和他的船“阿加皮诺号”正经由苏伊士运河回国，而那里正处于冲突的核心。我们当时在船队中。我们的船是倒数第二艘。不同国家的船只一起编队通过是很常见的，因为这样更容易控制交通。“阿加皮诺号”是编在一起的14艘货船和两艘油轮之一。航行没多久，船队就进入了苏伊士运河中一段被称为“大苦湖”的区域。这是运河中一片100平方英里的咸水水域。
Normally a ship like the Agapinor would anchor in the Great Bitter Lake for a few hours until the traffic cleared, but this time, the ship would be staying much longer. I relieved the chief officer at 8 o'clock, 0800, OK? The captain was in his cabin, and we were proceeding northbound through the southern part of the Suez Canal. It was early morning, and Flakid just taken up his post on the bridge of the ship. Shortly after I came on the bridge, the captain blew up to me. When I say blew up to me, we didn't have this modern communication.
通常像“阿加皮诺号”这样的船会在大苦湖抛锚几个小时，直到交通畅通，但这一次，船要停留更久。我在8点钟，即0800点，接替了大副，好吗？船长在船舱里，我们正向北穿过苏伊士运河南部。那是清晨，弗莱克刚在船桥上接岗。我上船桥后不久，船长就用传声筒叫我。我说传声筒，是因为我们当时没有现代通讯设备。
There's like a pipe, so you put your ear to it. Anyway, and he said, Peter, I've just heard on a BBC, a world service that was broken out. He said, if you see anything, let me know. Flags first instinct was to grab his camera. At 8.45am, Israeli warplanes cut through the quiet morning and shot in fast and low from the east directly over his head into Egypt. In the previous wars, it was always used to say how the planes, if an attack would happen, would be advantageous if they came out of the sun.
就像一根管子，你把耳朵贴上去。总之，他说：“彼得，我刚从BBC世界服务台听到战争爆发了。”他说：“如果你看到什么，告诉我。”弗莱克的第一反应是抓起他的相机。上午8点45分，以色列战机划破了宁静的早晨，从东方快速低空飞过他的头顶，进入埃及。在之前的战争中，人们总是说，如果发生袭击，从太阳方向飞来会更有利。
You know, because then you couldn't see them arrive. This is what exactly did happen. They came out of the sun from the east. Around 200 Israeli fighter pilots used the low position of the rising sun and the convoy of ships to mask a surprise blitz on Egypt. The planes were headed westward over the Suez Canal and straight for an Egyptian airbase near the convoy's position. We were caught up in a, as far as we were concerned, in a war zone.
你知道，因为那样你就看不见它们飞来。这正是发生的事情。它们从东方的太阳方向飞来。大约200名以色列战斗机飞行员利用初升太阳的低角度和船队作为掩护，对埃及发动了突然袭击。飞机向西飞越苏伊士运河，直奔船队位置附近的一个埃及空军基地。我们被卷入了，就我们而言，一个战区。
Flack in the rest of the crew suddenly had front row seats to the first wave of the six day war. The convoy of ships watched from their anchored positions as Israeli jets Unleashed gunfire and missiles on grounded Egyptian planes and after that first bombing raid the there's a cake fire going on as they Departed the Israelis departed after that first rate they came back over the convoy And using this convoy once again as a shield so that all the hair came fire. It was coming towards us, so we all did have y'all stuck. Israel claims to have destroyed the bulk of the Arab Air Forces in the air and on the ground in less than three hours.
弗莱克和其余船员突然成了“六日战争”第一波袭击的前排观众。船队从抛锚的位置看着以色列喷气式飞机对地面上的埃及飞机发动枪击和导弹袭击。在那次轰炸之后，当他们离开时，防空炮火还在响。以色列人在那次袭击后离开了，他们又飞回船队上方，再次利用船队作为盾牌，这样所有的防空炮火都朝我们打来，所以我们都趴下了。以色列声称在不到三个小时内就在空中和地面摧毁了阿拉伯空军的主力。
The mites of Egypt's Russian equipment are to have been completely shattered. Amazingly no one in the convoy was hurt, but the Egyptian Air Force had been destroyed. After the attack, the Suez Canal became the dividing line between Egyptian forces on the west side and Israeli forces on the east, with the great bitter lake right in the middle. The convoy was sandwiched between two warring armies. This is Kath Sanker, author of Stranded in the Six Day War. With the war going on, I mean, they were ordered over the radio, you know, to stop where they were and to await further instructions.
埃及的俄制装备据称已被彻底粉碎。令人惊讶的是，船队中没有人受伤，但埃及空军已被摧毁。袭击发生后，苏伊士运河成了西岸埃及军队和东岸以色列军队之间的分界线，大苦湖就在中间。船队被夹在两支交战军队之间。这是《困在六日战争中》的作者凯丝·桑克。随着战争的进行，我的意思是，他们通过无线电接到命令，停在原地，等待进一步指示。
The convoy was made up of commercial ships and had no choice but to comply with Egyptian authorities, as East Fire was reached in less than a week, but the diplomatic conflict dragged on. Egypt ordered a complete standstill of the Suez Canal. It was a defensive mechanism. Firstly, they did not want Israel to have access to the canal. It was something that they could do because they were in control of it, and they could
船队由商船组成，别无选择，只能服从埃及当局，因为不到一周就达成了停火，但外交冲突却拖延了下来。埃及下令苏伊士运河彻底停航。这是一种防御机制。首先，他们不想让以色列进入运河。这是他们能做到的，因为他们控制着运河，他们可以
control the traffic. And that way nobody could use use it and no hostile power could get in there Even if the 14 ships wanted to go rogue and leave against orders, they physically couldn't The Egyptian government figured the best way to prevent Israel from using the canal was to block it entirely So a few days after the conflict started they dumped debris through in land mines and scuttled old ships to make the canal impassable. The convoy was completely trapped. After a few days when we thought, well, we're not going anywhere here. It's just a case of waiting. The 14 trap ships came from eight different countries, the UK, West Germany, Poland, Czechoslovakia, Sweden, France, Bulgaria, and the United States. In the beginning, the crews didn't know what was going on.
控制交通。这样谁也用不了，任何敌对势力也进不去。即使这14艘船想违抗命令离开，在物理上也做不到。埃及政府认为防止以色列使用运河的最好办法就是彻底封锁它。因此，在冲突开始几天后，他们倾倒了碎片、埋设了地雷并凿沉了旧船，使运河无法通行。船队被彻底困住了。几天后，我们想，好吧，我们哪儿也去不了。只能等着。这14艘被困船只来自8个不同的国家：英国、西德、波兰、捷克斯洛伐克、瑞典、法国、保加利亚和美国。起初，船员们不知道发生了什么。
The only information we got was through the World Service and the Merchant Navy program. There was no mail. I've still got a letter to prepare so they knew when I'd be arriving home. Despite the lack of communication, the shipping companies were working in the background to get their crews home while the United Nations tried to work out a deal to reopen the canal. A six-day Middle East war echoes along a second front. The diplomatic struggle at the United Nations Security Council, A series of emotionally charged meetings. Months dragged on and the boats still hadn't been released. They were stranded for so long
我们得到的唯一信息是通过世界服务台和商船队节目。没有邮件。我还有一封信要准备，这样他们就知道我什么时候到家。尽管缺乏沟通，航运公司仍在幕后努力让船员回家，而联合国则试图达成重新开放运河的协议。中东六日战争在第二条战线上产生回响。联合国安理会的外交斗争，一系列充满情绪的会议。几个月过去了，船只仍未获释。他们被困了太久，
the convoy earned the nickname the yellow fleet because the sandstorms in the region stained the holes of the ships. It was surprising how the days did pass so there were others who didn't accept it, you know, batting at the bit, but I thought, well, this is our lot. After three months of the crews trying to maintain their ships and their sanity, the shipping companies and the Egyptian government
船队赢得了“黄色舰队”的绰号，因为该地区的沙尘暴染黄了船体。令人惊讶的是，日子竟然就这样过去了，有些人无法接受，急不可耐，但我心想，好吧，这就是我们的命。在船员们努力维护船只和保持理智三个月后，航运公司和埃及政府
finally reached a compromise. The people trapped on board were released and Peter Flack and the rest of the stranded crew finally went home. I got back home, I'd carried on as normal, I'd go to a single as I say, I was, so I'd go on to a dance, you know, me to go, you know, for three weeks, you know, and have a good time and then go back to see that's how it was Vivian. But Egypt wouldn't reopen the canal, so while the sailors could go home, the ships had to stay.
终于达成了妥协。被困在船上的人获释了，彼得·弗莱克和其余被困船员终于回到了家。我回到家，一切照旧，我去参加舞会，你知道，去玩三个星期，玩得很开心，然后又回到海上，事情就是这样，薇薇安。但埃及拒绝重新开放运河，所以虽然水手们可以回家，但船只必须留下。
And the shipping companies didn't want to completely abandon their vessels. So the logical thing to do was to keep people there to protect the valuable cargo and the investment that they've made in the ships. Every shipping company decided to recruit new crew members to keep the vessels in working condition, with the understanding that they would set sail the moment the passage reopened. While Peter Flaack was busy dancing with the ladies back home in Liverpool, a fresh batch of seafarers were sent to take his place. It couldn't wait to go home, of course.
航运公司不想彻底放弃他们的船只。因此，合乎逻辑的做法是留人看守，以保护宝贵的货物和他们对船只的投资。每家航运公司都决定招募新船员来保持船只处于工作状态，并达成共识：一旦航道重新开放，他们就会立即启航。当彼得·弗莱克在利物浦老家忙着和女士们跳舞时，一批新的海员被派去接替他的位置。当然，他们迫不及待地想回家。
So it was a new adventure for us and we just took it off from there. This is George Wharton, one of the members of that first relief crew. At the time, he was just 24 years old with the new wife and a baby on the way. Even with the risk of being in a conflict zone, going to the Great bitter lake was considered a pretty good gig. Unlike the first wave of sailors caught in the Six Day War, the replacement crews knew exactly what they were getting into, and they were offered double pay because of the ever present threat to war. It was classed as a good job and people when you fit when I was offered it and it worked around and said, oh aren't you lucky you know. The work was like being on any other
所以这对我们来说是一次新的冒险，我们就从那里开始了。这是乔治·沃顿，第一批救援船员之一。当时他才24岁，新婚燕尔，孩子也快出生了。即使有身处冲突地区的风险，去大苦湖也被认为是一份相当不错的工作。与第一波被困在六日战争中的水手不同，接替的船员很清楚自己要面对什么，而且由于战争威胁始终存在，他们获得了双倍工资。这被归类为一份好工作，当我被录用时，周围的人都说，哦，你真幸运。工作就像在任何其他
ship. There was a lot of cleaning running the engines and checking the cargo to make sure it kept fresh in the hot climate. But since they were in the middle of a lake in the middle of a desert in the middle of a war zone, Wharton says it was hard to get supplies. We started to run out of stores, you weren't going hungry or anything, but you were limited to the variety, if you like. The crews quickly realized that between the 14 ships, they actually had plenty. If they pulled their resources and traded with one another, they'd have enough of everything to go around.
船上一样。有很多清洁工作、运行发动机和检查货物，以确保它们在炎热的气候下保持新鲜。但由于他们身处沙漠中、战区中的湖泊中央，沃顿说很难获得补给。我们开始耗尽库存，你不会挨饿，但种类有限。船员们很快意识到，这14艘船加起来，其实物资很充足。如果他们整合资源并互相交易，他们就有足够的各种东西。
They wanted to swap, you know, sugar or tea or eggs. They realized that between the, you know, all the different ships that they had wide variety of supplies. One German ship had a ton of frozen meat. Another had way too much canned fruit, so they started trading. Wharton took a lifeboat from ship to ship. At first trading food, then swapping movie reels and bartering cigarettes. There was one ship, a checklist of academic ship, and if he went over to that ship, what
他们想交换糖、茶或鸡蛋。他们意识到，在所有不同的船只之间，他们有各种各样的补给。一艘德国船有一吨冷冻肉。另一艘有太多的罐装水果，所以他们开始交易。沃顿乘救生艇往返于各船之间。起初是交易食物，然后交换电影胶片，再用香烟易货。有一艘捷克学术船，如果你去那艘船，
a welcome they would give you. They would open a bottle of whiskey, throw the co-ocaway. You could not leave the ship to that whiskey was gone. Soon they started hanging out a lot, and because they were a bunch of 20-something year old sailors, they started hanging out a lot, and because there were a bunch of 20-something-year-old sailors, they started partying a lot. Some of the captains, they were a little bit concerned, because clearly in the early days, you know, there was a kind of lot of drinking and just sort of hanging out and sleeping. And, you know, they were kind of thinking, well, you know, it would be good to kind of get together and organize some social activities.
他们会给你什么样的欢迎啊。他们会打开一瓶威士忌，把瓶塞扔掉。除非威士忌喝完，否则你不能离开那艘船。很快他们开始频繁聚会，因为他们是一群20多岁的水手，他们开始频繁聚会，因为他们是一群20多岁的水手，他们开始频繁聚会。一些船长有点担心，因为显然在早期，你知道，有很多喝酒和闲逛、睡觉的情况。而且，你知道，他们心想，嗯，组织一些社交活动会比较好。
They were worried that boredom would set in and then people would, you know, there would be, you know, people would get irritated. The captains figured a little structure would curb the worst behavior of their sailors. So in October of 1967, five months after the start of the Six Day War, they made a plan. Warton remembers seeing a notice on the bulletin board addressed to all the seafarers on the lake. Dear all, at a recent meeting attended by personnel from all the ships at present in the bitter lakes, it was decided to form an association to be called the Great Bitter Lake Association. The main aim of the association is to maintain and foster the many friendships that we have and no doubt you have formed with the people of the other
他们担心无聊会产生，然后人们会变得烦躁。船长们认为一点组织结构会遏制水手们最糟糕的行为。因此，在1967年10月，即六日战争开始五个月后，他们制定了一个计划。沃顿记得在公告栏上看到一张写给湖上所有海员的通知。亲爱的各位，在最近一次由目前在大苦湖的所有船只人员参加的会议上，决定成立一个协会，名为“大苦湖协会”。协会的主要目的是维持和促进我们在这里与来自其他
ships and other nationalities whilst here. The Great Bitter Lake Association was a way to regulate the unofficial marketplace that it sprung up between the ships and bring some order to their makeshift community. It was also a social committee. Membership in the GBLA included events hosted each week by a different vessel. Ships modified their lifeboats into sailboats and took turns hosting regottas. One ship built a functional soccer pitch on its deck in held tournaments. The Polish ship had a doctor and became the de facto medical center.
船只和其他国籍的人所建立的许多友谊。大苦湖协会是一种规范船只之间自发形成的非官方市场的方式，并为他们的临时社区带来一些秩序。它也是一个社交委员会。大苦湖协会的成员资格包括每周由不同船只举办的活动。船只将救生艇改装成帆船，轮流举办帆船赛。一艘船在甲板上建造了一个功能齐全的足球场并举行了锦标赛。波兰船上有一名医生，成了事实上的医疗中心。
The sweetest ship had a gym. And even though the Great Bitter Lake Association was originally formed to curb drinking, a lot of alcohol was still consumed on the Great Bitter Lake Association was originally formed to curb drinking, a lot of alcohol was still consumed on the Great Bitter Lake. One chip captain estimated that perhaps 1.5 million empty beer bottles may have been dumped into the lake, writing, quote, one wonders what future archaeologists in a few thousand years' time will think of this. I think he's on the rest of it. I think off of those ships were a ground on bottles. But even though it may sound like the GBLA devolved into a fleet of partyboats, the association
瑞典船有一个健身房。尽管大苦湖协会最初是为了遏制酗酒而成立的，但大苦湖上仍然消耗了大量的酒精。一位船长估计，可能有150万个空啤酒瓶被扔进了湖里，他写道：“人们不禁会想，几千年后的未来考古学家会怎么看这些。”我想他说的其余部分也是如此。我想那些船的一半都堆满了瓶子。但尽管听起来大苦湖协会似乎演变成了一支派对船队，但该协会
was actually there to create a sense of stability in an incredibly unstable place. The sailors weren't just individuals on a ship, but members of a society. The sailors weren't just individuals on a ship, but members of a society. Everybody in the GBLA was given a specially designed bitter-like themed necktie in badge. The badge itself was in the shape of a shield, with a large anchor across the center. At the top were the letters GBLA, and the bottom was the number 14 for the 14 ships in the lake. Running diagonally behind the anchor with a thin blue strip to represent the Suez Canal. What was interesting was that you have western, those from western nations, from western
实际上是为了在一个极其不稳定的地方创造一种稳定感。水手们不仅仅是船上的个体，更是社会的一员。大苦湖协会的每个人都获得了一枚特别设计的大苦湖主题领带和徽章。徽章本身呈盾形，中间有一枚大锚。顶部是字母“GBLA”，底部是数字“14”，代表湖中的14艘船。锚后斜穿过一条细蓝带，代表苏伊士运河。有趣的是，你有西方人，那些来自西方国家，来自当时的西德、法国、英国和美国。另一方面，你有来自东方集团国家的船只，保加利亚船、波兰船和捷克船，所以你就在大苦湖那里看到了冷战的缩影。该组织的第一项决定是，无论来自哪里，每个人都是平等的。无论船员来自哪里，他们都把本国的政治抛在脑后。当船员们聚在一起庆祝他们的第一个重大节日时，这一点尤为明显，
Germany as it then was France, Britain and the USA. On the other side you had from the eastern block countries, the Bulgarian ship, the Polar ships and the Czech ship, so you kind of had the kind of microcosm of the Cold War going on right there in the Great Bitter Lake. And the first decision of that organisation was that everybody would be equal wherever they were from. No matter where the crews came from, they left the politics of their home countries aside. This was especially true when the crews came together to celebrate their first big holiday
作为一个群体。第一个圣诞节。那真是一个难忘的夜晚。沃顿在海上度过了他那份份额的圣诞节，但这次与他经历过的任何一次都不同。波兰船员制作了一棵巨大的圣诞树，把它安装在木筏上，锚定在所有船只的中间。圣诞夜，所有的船只都被邀请到树旁，我们都系在树周围。我们举行了颂歌仪式。其中一艘船上甚至有一架风琴，所以我们有音乐，大家都唱颂歌。
as a group. The first Christmas. That really was a night to remember. Warden has spent more than his fair share of Christmases at sea, but this one was unlike any he had ever experienced. The polar cement made this huge Christmas tree and mounted it on a raft and anchored it in the middle of all the ships. And our Christmas night, all the boats were invited over to the tree and we tied all tied up around the tree. And we had a cattle service. One of the boats actually had an organ in it, and so we had music and all sang cattle.
听德国人用他们的语言唱《平安夜》，哦，你可以想象在沙漠中央，头顶上有数百万颗星星。听他们唱歌真是太不可思议了。沃顿在假期后愉快地回到了家，见到了他的妻子和刚出生的女儿。他以为他在湖上的时光是一次千载难逢的经历，但令他惊讶的是，一年后，联合国还没有找到解决方案。船只仍然在运河里，他有机会回去。船长打电话来说，嗯，如你所知，船还在那里，你想回去吗？
To listen to the Germans sing silent night in their language, oh, you imagine in the middle of the desert it's like a million stars just above your head. It was just incredible to listen to them. The Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of the Holy Spirit of Wharton happily returned home after the holidays to his wife and brand new daughter. He figured his time in the lake was a once in a lifetime experience, but to his surprise, a year later, the UN hadn't figured out a solution. The ships were still in the canal, and he was given a chance to go back. The bus call made a gettish and said, well, as you know, the ships are still there, do you want to go back there?
嗯，我建议，嗯，如你所知，船还在那里。你想回去吗？嗯，我建议，当然。当你回到湖上时，沃顿意识到协会变得比他离开时更重要了。在兄弟情谊、体育运动和官方徽章之间，大苦湖协会开始感觉不仅仅是一个俱乐部。还有一个想法是，大苦湖中间的船只形成了它们自己的小
Well, I suggest, well, as you know, the ships are still there. Do you want to go back there? Well, I suggest, definitely. When you got back to the lake, Wharton realized the association had become more important than when he left. Between the brotherhood, the sports, and the official badges, the Great Bitter Lake Association started feeling like something bigger than just a club. There was also an idea that the ships in the middle of the Great Bitter Lake formed that own little
自治社区。大苦湖协会感觉不像是一支国际船队。它感觉更像是一个自己的国家。因此，作为一个小国家，他们应该有自己的邮票。每枚邮票都是由协会成员手工制作和设计的，需要极大的足智多谋。我认为非凡之处在于创造这些微小艺术品所投入的工艺水平，使用他们能找到的任何材料。咖啡渣可能被用来
autonomous community. The GBLA didn't feel like a convoy of international ships. It felt more like its own nation. And therefore, as a little nation, they should have their own postage stump. Each stamp was handcrafted and designed by members of the association and required a lot of resourcefulness. I think the extraordinary thing is the level of craftsmanship that went into creating these tiny, tiny works of art, using whatever materials they could find. Coffee grounds might be used
制造沙子或任何他们能找到的东西。他们还使用蜡笔、土豆皮，有些甚至是用黄铜雕刻或蚀刻出来的。邮票使用一种类似粗糙复印机的“胶版印刷机”进行复制，并分发给其他成员。从技术上讲，这些邮票是“灰姑娘邮票”，没有邮政价值，主要是为了自娱自乐，但有些确实作为正式邮资通过了。我们开始把它们贴在信封上，其中一些被埃及政府接受，并作为邮资，信件也寄回了家。我有几枚带鸟的邮票。
to create sand or anything that they could find really. They also used crayons, potato skins, and some were even carved or etched out of brass. The stamps were copied using a hector graph, which is kind of like a crude copier, and distributed to the rest of the members. Technically, these stamps were Cinderella stamps, with no postal value, and were made mostly for their own amusement, but some actually made it through as official postage. We started putting them on our envelopes and some of them were accepted by the Egyptian government and the council of them is post and the lessons got back home. I have a couple of the stamps that have birds.
他们用鸟来象征自由，基本上是摆脱被困在苏伊士运河的自由。我知道其中一些描绘显示鸟被系在锚上。这是埃里克·卡尔森，刚才提到的集邮家。邮票通常以航海意象为特色，如船只和锚。偶尔他们会有女士的照片，因为，你知道，水手。许多这些邮票在设计上确实有一种纹身般的质感。每枚邮票上的艺术品就像一个微小的时间胶囊，
They did birds to symbolize freedom, basically freedom from being stranded in the Suez. And I know some of these depictions show the birds tied to an anchor. This is Eric Carlson, the Philatalyst from earlier. The stamps often featured nautical imagery, like ships and anchors. And occasionally they had pictures of ladies because, you know, sailors. A lot of these stamps do have a kind of a tattoo quality to them in their straightforwardness of the design. The artwork on each stamp acted like a tiny time capsule
记录了他们的经历。他们记录了圣诞节、周年纪念日、足球锦标赛，甚至是为了纪念1968年墨西哥城奥运会而举办的大苦湖奥运会。但大苦湖协会的鼎盛时期不可能永远持续下去。1973年，在赎罪日战争期间，一枚流弹击中并沉没了一艘名为“非洲格伦号”的美国船只。
of their experiences. They documented Christmases, anniversaries, soccer tournaments, even a great bitter lake Olympics that they held in honor of the 1968 Mexico City Games. But the heyday of the great Bitter Lake Association couldn't last forever. In 1973, during the Yom Kupur War, a stray missile hit and sank an American vessel called the African Glen.
谢天谢地，没有人丧生。随着时间的推移，航运公司将人员减少到最低限度，同时他们的船只也在缓慢腐烂。到1974年，当达成重新开放运河的协议时，大多数船只已不再适航。协议达成后，清理阻塞航道的碎片花了一整年时间。有100个桥梁部分、20辆卡车、8辆坦克、100艘船只和75万个爆炸装置被扔进了苏伊士运河的水域。最终，在1975年，即六日战争开始八年后，这些船只被
Thankfully, no one was killed. Over time, the shipping companies reduced their personnel to skeleton crews, all the while their ships were slowly decaying. By 1974, when a deal was broker to reopen the canal, most of the ships were no longer seeworthy. After the agreement, it took a full year to remove the debris blocking the passage. There were a hundred bridge sections, twenty trucks, eight tanks, a hundred vessels, and 750,000 explosive devices thrown into the waters of the Suez. And finally, in 1975, eight years after the start of the Six Day War, the ships were
拖走，并向大苦湖做了最后的告别。苏伊士运河从埃尔费丹大桥到塞得港已开辟出一条清晰的航道。13艘被困的商船终于能够起锚，驶向开阔的地中海。他们甚至用最后一套写着“G-B-L-A告别”的邮票纪念了这一时刻。彼得·弗莱克，在六日战争开始时就在船上，他说海员之间形成如此深厚的纽带是非常
towed out and said their final goodbyes to the great bitter leg. A clear passage has been made up the Suez Canal from the Elfer Dan bridge to port side. And 13 marooned merchant ships have it last been able to pull up their hooks and head towards the open Mediterranean. They even commemorated the moment with one last set of stamps that said G-B-L-A farewell. Peter Flack, who was on board at the start of the Six-Day War, says that it's pretty
罕见的。你出去，尽力与船员相处，然后转到下一份工作。他说，商船队的人甚至有一个术语，叫“贸易委员会熟人”。你知道，我们只是待在自己的船上，就是这样。船友们保持联系是非常罕见的。但从1967年到1975年，超过3000名男性和一名女性实际上
rare for seafarers to form such a strong bond. You go out, you try your best to get along with your crew, and then you move on to the next job. He says there's even a term for people who serve in the merchant navy, the board of trade acquaintances. You know, we just stick to our ships and that was it. It's very rare, do we, did shipmates keep in touch. But from 1967 to 1975, over 3,000 men and one woman actually
在大苦湖上并肩工作。2017年，他们在利物浦举行了50周年重聚，德国和斯洛伐克的成员至今仍每年聚会。50多年后，这仍然是一个安静的传统。大苦湖协会在六日战争复杂的历史中大多只是一个脚注，但这里那里有一些小碎片提醒世界其他地方，这个临时国家曾经存在过。你可以在设计精美的徽章中找到它们，
served alongside each other on the grape at her lake. In 2017, they held a 50-year reunion in Liverpool, and members in Germany and Slovakia still meet up annually. It remains a quiet tradition over 50 years later. The GBLA is mostly a footnote in the complicated history of the Six-Day War, but there are little pieces here and there that remind the rest of the world that this makeshift nation once existed. You could find them in a well-designed badge,
定制的领带，或者你在eBay上偶然发现的一枚邮票。薇薇安稍后会回来讲述另一个关于邮票和运河的故事。现在我和薇薇安在演播室里，你要给我们讲另一个关于历史邮票的故事。是的。信不信由你，我还有另一个关于集邮和运河交叉点的故事。你为自己开辟了一个相当狭窄的报道领域。这是我的，我的
a custom necktie, or a stamp that you stumble across on eBay. Vivian comes back with another story about stamps and canals after this. So now I'm in the studio with Vivian and you're going to tell us another story about historical stamps. Yes. And believe it or not, I have another story at the intersection of Philataly and canals. That's quite a narrow, Venn diagram of beet coverage you've carved out for yourself. It's my, it's my
报道，我的9PI报道。它有体育，我有运河/邮票。它有体育，体育和鱼，纽约运河和邮票。好吧，告诉我们吧。好的，巴拿马运河基本上连接了大西洋和太平洋。但你知道它差点建在尼加拉瓜而不是巴拿马吗？我的意思是，我想我隐约记得在巴拿马还是尼加拉瓜之间有一点反复，但我不知道细节。所以，在19世纪初，国会决定他们想在尼加拉瓜而不是巴拿马建造。哦，好吧。为什么呢？所以，原因有很多。基本上，法国大约20年前曾试图在巴拿马建造运河。
beat, my 9PI beat. And it has sports and I have canals slash stamps. It has sports, sports and fish, New York canals and stamps. Okay, tell us about it. Okay, so the Panama Canal basically connects the Atlantic and the Pacific. But did you know that it was almost built in Nicaragua instead of Panama? I mean, I think I vaguely remember that there was a little bit of a back and forth as to
它惨败了，仅仅因为巴拿马的地形多山，雨季导致了洪水和泥石流。很多人死于黄热病和疟疾。所以尼加拉瓜的地形看起来更容易建造。而且它还有一个巨大的湖泊，这是一种天然水体，运河可以流经它。所以那里已经有了一条部分水道。当你看到地理位置时，你会觉得巴拿马很有道理，因为它在那里非常狭窄，正好位于北美和南美之间的分界点。而尼加拉瓜要大得多，但那个湖有帮助，而且它不那么崎岖
it being a Panama or a Nicaragua, but I don't know the details of that. So, in the early 1800s, Congress had decided that they wanted to build a Nicaragua rather than Panama. Oh, okay. And why was that? So, there's a bunch of reasons. So basically, France had attempted to build a canal through Panama about 20 years earlier.
也有帮助。是的，所以它会是一条更长的运河，但总的来说，施工会更简单。是的，而且在当时，也就是20世纪初，巴拿马仍然是哥伦比亚的一个省，还不是一个独立的国家。所以在地质和政治上，美国认为尼加拉瓜会是一个更好的选择。好吧。如果尼加拉瓜在当时是一个更有意义的地点，为什么他们最终决定选择巴拿马？所以这基本上是因为这两个游说者。一个是名叫威廉·尼尔森·克伦威尔的美国律师，另一个是名叫菲利普·布诺-瓦里拉的法国工程师。
It failed miserably just because the terrain of Panama is like mountainous and the rainy season caused like flooding and mudslides. So many people died of yellow fever and malaria. So the terrain of Nicaragua seemed a lot simpler to build through. And it also has this giant lake that was kind of a natural body water that the canal can flow through. So there was already like a partial waterway right there. When you see the geography, you think Panama makes a lot of sense because it's really thin right there and it's right at that dividing point between North and South America. And Nicaragua is much bigger, but that lake kind of helps and it not being mountainous
布诺-瓦里拉实际上参与了20年前的法国巴拿马运河项目。但他真的很想留在项目中，因为他在巴拿马运河公司拥有巨大的股份。所以他雇佣了克伦威尔来帮助他游说国会在巴拿马而不是尼加拉瓜建造。他们是如何在经历了一系列灾难后说服国会巴拿马比尼加拉瓜更好的？
kind of helps. Yeah, so it would be a longer canal, but it would just be simpler altogether for construction. Yeah, and also at the time, which is like the early 1900s, Panama was still a province of Colombia and not an independent nation yet. So geologically and politically, the US thought that Nicaragua would be a better choice. Okay. So if Nicaragua was a location that made more sense at the time, why did they end up ultimately deciding to go with Panama? So it was basically because of these two lobbyists. One was an American attorney named William Nelson Cromwell, and the other was a French engineer named Philippe Buno-Varilla.
一个因素是，你知道，要在尼加拉瓜建造，运河必须更长。所以出于实际目的，施工量会更大。但他们还使用了一枚邮票。他们用一枚邮票说服了他们。是的。他们是怎么做到的？所以尼加拉瓜有一座名为莫莫通博山的火山，它是尼加拉瓜深受喜爱的象征，
And Buno-Varilla was actually involved in the French Panama Canal project from like 20 years earlier. But he really wanted to stay on the project because he owned this big stake in the Panama Canal company. So he hired Cromwell to help him lobby Congress to build in Panama rather than Nicaragua. And how did they manage to convince Congress that Panama would be better than Nicaragua after this long series of disasters?
但在同一时间，也就是1902年左右，马提尼克的培雷火山爆发，造成3万人死亡。哇，好吧。所以这发生在国会应该决定运河项目之前。所以，布诺-瓦里拉和克伦威尔提出了一个论点，即由于所有这些火山活动，尼加拉瓜是一个糟糕的选择。
One element was that, you know, to build through Nicaragua, the Canal would just have to be longer. So like for practical purposes, it would just be more construction. But they also used a stamp. They used a stamp to convince them. Yes. How did they do that? So Nicaragua has a volcano called Mount Momotomo, which is this beloved symbol of Nicaragua,
为了进一步证明他们的观点，他们转向了1900年1月1日的尼加拉瓜三美分邮票。我有一张那样的照片。所以。就是这个。这就是它的样子。好吧，所以它写着尼加拉瓜。
but around the same time, which was around 1902, Mount Pale and Martinique erupted and killed 30,000 people. Wow, OK. So this happened right before Congress was supposed to decide on the canal project. So, Bueno Varia and Kromel made this argument that Nicaragua was a bad choice because of all this volcanic activity.
这是一枚三美分的邮票。你看到了，它看起来……你看到背景里的火山了。但它是在喷发吗？看起来火山里有烟冒出来。是的，我猜我的怀疑是，它不是一座非常活跃的火山，但他们只是把它描绘成那样。所以，就像，是的，你知道，你看到一座火山，它是你
So to further prove their point, they turned to the January 1st, 1900, three cent stamp of Nicaragua. And I have a picture of that. So. That's it. This is what it looks like. Okay, so it says Nicaragua.
国家的象征，你会希望它做点什么。是的，好吧。它不会喷发。但是，是的，所以，他们的论点基本上是尼加拉瓜有太多的火山活动，以至于他们把它印在了这张国家邮票上。所以克伦威尔和布诺-瓦里拉所做的是，他们买了大约500张这样的尼加拉瓜邮票，并寄给众议院和参议院的每一位成员，附上一张纸条，上面写着“尼加拉瓜地峡火山活动的官方见证”。
It's a three-cent stamp. And you see it, and it looks... You see the volcano in the background. But is it kind of erupting? It looks like there's smoke building out of this volcano. Yeah, and I guess my suspicion is, it was not a very active volcano, but they just painted it as such. So, like, it's just a, yeah, you know, you see a volcano, it's like a symbol of your
所以这只是一个巨大的游说活动的一部分。这只是其中的一个因素，但它可能确实对他们的案件有帮助。哇。所以他们利用自己的邮票让它看起来比实际更危险，并以此来对付他们。是的。我想我们肯定会思考邮票是如何，
country, you're going to want it doing something. Yeah, okay. It's not going to erupt. But, yeah, so, their argument was basically that Nicaragua has so much volcanic activity that they put it on this national stamp. So what Cromwell and Bunova Ria did was they bought like 500 of these Nicaraguan stamps and sent them to each member of the House in the Senate with a note that said an official witness of the volcanic activity on the isthmus of Nicaragua.
正如你在故事中提到的，这是一个伟大的历史文献，无论它们是否是我们看待自己和正式展示自己的方式。但发现一个邮票实际上改变了历史的故事很有趣。是的，它是历史的积极参与者。哦，太酷了。
And so this was just part of like a huge lobbying campaign. It was like one element of it, but it probably did help their case. Wow. So they made it seem like a more dangerous place than it was because of their own stamp and used it against them. Yes. I think that we definitely think of how stamps,
我还有一个关于这个故事的补充。布诺-瓦里拉成为了巴拿马的大使。他的妻子实际上提议了一个巴拿马国旗的设计，我想给你看，因为这是我见过的最糟糕的旗帜之一。真的吗？好吧，它不是现在的那一面。不，不，不，我喜欢。它是当前的旗帜。它是我世界上最喜欢的旗帜之一。当前的巴拿马国旗是，是的。我喜欢它。
as you mentioned in the story, there's this great document of history, whether or not they are kind of how we see ourselves and present ourselves officially. But it's funny to find a story where the stamp actually changes history. Yeah, it's an active participant in the history. Oh, that's so cool.
好吧。但这就是布诺所做的。我想让旗帜看起来像。天哪。太糟糕了。所以它看起来像美国国旗的变体。是的。红黄条纹。
I have one last button to the story. Bunova dea became an ambassador to Panama. And his wife actually proposed a design for a flag of Panama, and I'd like to show it to you because it's one of the worst flags I've ever seen. Really? Okay, well, it's not the one that is present right now. No, no, no, I love. It's a current flag. It's one of my favorite flags in the world. The current Panama flag is Yes. I like it.
关于这个故事我还有一个最后的补充。布诺瓦·迪亚成为了巴拿马大使。他的妻子实际上为巴拿马国旗提出了一个设计方案，我想给你看看，因为那是我见过最糟糕的国旗之一。真的吗？好吧，它不是现在使用的那面。不，不，不，我喜欢现在的国旗。它是世界上我最喜欢的国旗之一。现在的巴拿马国旗是吗？是的。我很喜欢它。
Okay. But this is what Bunova did. I wanted the flag to look like. Oh my goodness. Great as me. And so it looks like a variation of the American flag. Yeah. Red and yellow stripes.
好吧。但这就是布诺瓦当时想要国旗呈现的样子。天哪。真是太糟糕了。它看起来像是美国国旗的变体。是的。红黄相间的条纹。
There's the stripes. Yeah. And then there's a blue canton. Mm-hmm. And in the blue canton, there's supposed to be, it's supposed to look like two suns being bridged together kind of like the bridging of the Pacific and the Atlantic. Yeah. But it looks like something else to me. It was like Harry balls. Yeah. No, trying to say. I was I I wasn't sure if it was like
有条纹。对。然后有一个蓝色方块。嗯。在蓝色方块里，本意应该是看起来像两个太阳连接在一起，有点像太平洋和大西洋的连接。对。但对我来说它看起来像别的东西。就像睾丸一样。对。不，我想说的是。我，我，我不确定它是不是像
my fifth grader brain that went to it. So okay. Yeah. No, this is the Harry ball flag of minimal. Yeah. Yeah, that's not good. That's not good. That's not good at all. But so everyone should look that up just to see it. But also look up the flag of Panama because I think it's actually, it's, it's, as these quarters and, and red and blue, you know, counterpoints, it's really, really beautiful. It's gorgeous. It's really beautiful.
我五年级的大脑想到的那样。好吧。对。不，这就是那个睾丸旗帜，极简主义的。对。对，那可不好。那不好。那一点也不好。但每个人都应该去查一下看看。但也去查一下巴拿马的国旗，因为我觉得它实际上，它，它，作为这些象限，还有红色和蓝色，你知道，对比色，它真的，真的很美。它太漂亮了。它真的很美。
Oh, well, I got to see a really ugly flag and we got to talk about stamps. So I consider this and balls and so I consider this a very successful discussion. Great. Thanks. Thank you. Thank you. 99% of Asible was produced this week by Vivian Le.
哦，好吧，我看到了一个非常丑的旗帜，我们还聊了邮票。所以我认为这和睾丸一样，所以我认为这是一次非常成功的讨论。太棒了。谢谢。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》由Vivian Le制作。
So, okay, so I'm in the street with Vivian Le. So Vivian,. So, okay, so I'm in the stream with Vivian Le. So Vivian, for two years, I've been saying your name Vivianly because I was told your name was Vivianly. By you. I told you my name was Vivianly. Okay, okay. But now I credit you and your listeners will know that I credit you in the beginning of this piece as Vivian Le. So tell us why Vivian Le and not Vivian Le. So I'm Vietnamese American. So the traditional pronunciation of the last name LE is Le, but I'm used to calling myself Le because growing up, I like, if you come from a Vietnamese American family or like an immigrant family, you have like an
所以，好吧，我和Vivian Le在直播中。所以Vivian，两年来我一直叫你的名字Vivian Lee，因为有人告诉我你的名字是Vivian Lee。是你告诉我的。我告诉过你我的名字是Vivian Lee。好吧，好吧。但现在我向你致谢，听众们会知道我在节目开头把你称为Vivian Le。所以告诉我们为什么是Vivian Le而不是Vivian Lee。我是越南裔美国人。所以姓氏LE的传统发音是Le，但我习惯叫自己Lee，因为成长过程中，如果你来自越南裔美国人家庭或者移民家庭，你会有
American way of saying your name and a Vietnamese way of saying your name. So yeah, I just grew up feeling like Lee was my last name. And so hearing it any other way was kind of like it felt off from me. So I decided kind of recently that I'd prefer to go by lay just because I recently got married and I decided to keep my last name and I made a big stink out of it to my husband. And I figured like if I'm going to keep my name, I might as well keep the whole name, the way that I feel like I'm supposed to be pronouncing it. But the thing is, you know, a lot of people go by Lee.
一种美国式的名字发音和一种越南式的名字发音。所以是的，我从小就觉得Lee是我的姓。所以听到别的发音对我来说感觉不对劲。所以我最近决定，我更喜欢用Le，因为我最近结婚了，我决定保留我的姓氏，而且我对我丈夫坚持了这一点。我想如果我要保留我的名字，我最好保留我感觉应该发音的那个完整名字。但问题是，你知道，很多人都用Lee。
A lot of, I know like a ton of Vietnamese people with L.E. They prefer Lee and that's fine, but I think from now on I just prefer. Lay. Okay. Well, that's great. I'm happy to call you Vivian Lay. I'm happy to hear it. And I'm sorry that if you've ever felt like you couldn't bring up the change. No, not at all. Not at all. Yeah. Yeah. It was just a recent thing. It's like, you know what? Even if it brings me a little bit of discomfort, that will go away. And then from now on, this will just be my name.
很多，我知道有一大堆越南人用L.E.。他们更喜欢Lee，那没关系，但我认为从现在开始我只喜欢Le。好吧。嗯，那太好了。我很高兴叫你Vivian Le。我很高兴听到这个。如果你曾经觉得无法提出这个改变，我很抱歉。不，一点也不。完全没有。对。对。这只是最近的事。就像，你知道吗？即使这让我有一点不舒服，那也会消失的。从现在开始，这就是我的名字。
Is it uncomfortable to even talk about in this context? No, not really. It's more like when people would call me Vivian Lay, I wouldn't recognize it as much as Vivian Lay. Yeah, no, I get that. Yeah, but no, it's Vivian Lay. And we're drawing a line in the sand. This is where this is what's happening.
在这种情况下谈论它会感到不舒服吗？不，真的不会。更多的是当人们叫我Vivian Lee时，我不会像对Vivian Le那样有认同感。对，我明白。对，但不是，是Vivian Le。我们在沙地上画了一条线。这就是正在发生的事情。
It's pretty official. We're putting it on podcast. On the podcast. Okay, so everyone just, no, it's Vivian Lay, Ellie, saying this is where this is what's happened. It's pretty official. We're putting it on podcast. We're putting it on the podcast. Okay, so everyone just know it's Vivian Leigh. Ellie, Vivian Leigh. Great. Thank you. I'm glad we had this talk.
这很正式。我们把它放在播客里了。在播客上。好吧，所以每个人都知道，是Vivian Le，Le，这就是正在发生的事情。这很正式。我们把它放在播客里了。我们把它放在播客上了。好吧，所以每个人都知道是Vivian Le。Le，Vivian Le。太棒了。很高兴我们进行了这次谈话。
Good talk. Good talk. Thanks. 99% of visible with Bruce's week by Vivian Leigh. Mix and Deck production by Srivusif. Music by Sean Rial. Additional music in this episode was composed by Jenny Conley-Drizos, John Newfeld, and Nate Query.
谈得很好。谈得很好。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》由Vivian Le制作。混音和后期制作由Srivusif完成。音乐由Sean Rial创作。本集中的额外音乐由Jenny Conley-Drizos、John Newfeld和Nate Query创作。
Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead, is the digital director. The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Avery Trouffman, Joe Rosenberg, Delaney Hall, Chris Perrubay, Sophia Klatsger, and me Roman Mars. A very special thanks to the Gertlush choir for letting us use their beautiful rendition of Silent Night into Peter Volner. If you want to read more about the Great Biter Lake Association, you can find Kath Sinker's book, stranded in the Sixth Day War at KathSinker.co.uk, or you can get a digital download on Amazon. There were tons of really cool details that we couldn't get into this piece, so I really suggest you check it out. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown,
Katie Mingle是我们的高级制作人，Kurt Colstead是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Emmett Fitzgerald、Avery Trouffman、Joe Rosenberg、Delaney Hall、Chris Perrubay、Sophia Klatsger，还有我Roman Mars。特别感谢Gertlush合唱团让我们使用他们美丽的《平安夜》演绎版本，以及Peter Volner。如果你想阅读更多关于大苦湖协会的信息，你可以在KathSinker.co.uk找到Kath Sinker的书《困在六日战争中》，或者你可以在亚马逊上下载电子版。有很多非常酷的细节我们没能在这一集中深入探讨，所以我真的建议你去看看。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的市中心Radio Row制作，
Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or work. Run Instagram and read it too. Here's the moment where we always encourage you to stop by our website. But make sure you really do it this week because you can see GBLI stamps for yourself as well as some amazing photographs that Peter Flock personally took of the Six Day War in 1967 from the Great
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。《99%无形》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。你可以在radiotopia.fm找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注。这是我们总是鼓励你访问我们网站的时刻。但请确保你这周真的去看了，因为你可以亲自看到GBLI邮票，以及Peter Flock在1967年六日战争期间亲自拍摄的一些令人惊叹的照片，来自大
Bitter Lake. They're really amazing. They're at 99pi.org. Rx. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
苦湖。它们真的很棒。网址是99pi.org。Rx。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。